some of your holiday shopping items as
you heard we just heard us discussing
may be delayed by supply chain
bottlenecks at places like the ports of
los angeles and long beach workers who
help move our goods every day are trying
to clear a huge backlog of containers
carter evans got an inside look at the
unloading operation
with a record number of containers piled
high at the ports of l.a and long beach
idle cranes may be a surprising sight
there's no room in the yard to offload a
vessel local longshoremen union
president ramon ponce de leon took us
dockside to explain why it now takes so
much longer to unload these ships it's
normally cooking around here everybody's
moving but because there is no space in
the yard there's not that much we can
offload so that's why we're not seeing a
lot more cranes moving around that's
correct
increased consumer spending during the
pandemic led to even more imports
clogging up the pores do you guys take
pride in the amount of containers you
can move definitely it's like a game
it's a challenge it's fun you know
crane operator rick mccray used to work
a lot faster
how long would it take you in general to
unload a ship like this probably three
and a half four days how long has it
taken now it's taking about nine
sometimes longer
he can only unload a container when
there's a place to put it 20 million of
these 20 million gonna come through
these ports come to the ports poste leon
showed us row after row piled high
you may think these trucks line up for
the first load available but that is not
the case they are here for specific
containers and sometimes they're in the
middle of the pile
it's like a giant game of jenga move
four containers just to get to one on
the bottom how long are these containers
waiting here on average now do you know
the dwell time here is over nine days
add that to the time it now takes to
offload and it could be 18 days before
these containers even leave the dock
the new infrastructure law has 17
billion earmark for the nation's ports
and longshoremen say spending on port
rail improvements will help we can load
in about a five hour period about 300
containers on a rail these are big money
projects that take a long time yes they
do just this week the u.s navy announced
it would allow containers to be stored
at the port wineme naval base welcome
news to longshoremen whatever it takes
to give us some fluidity some breathing
space in the terminals so we can move
the containers a lot faster meanwhile
the white house says many big box
retailers are promising to schedule more
overnight pickups if they commit to pick
up containers then we will be able to
move these and catch back up but until
then it's not going to happen for cbs
mornings i'm carter evans in long beach